foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing how Severus Snape knew the
location of Harry and Hermione in The
Forest of Dean in the Deathly Hallows
airing the trio or out hunting horcruxes
however things aren't going particularly
well and that's because they are without
the fabled Sword of Gryffindor a weapon
they can use to destroy these evil items
cue Severus Snape after a considerable
amount of time had passed and the trio
had managed to Traverse miles upon miles
of forest Severus Snape decides its time
to drop off the Sword of Gryffindor
which was in his possession Dumbledore
instructs Snape to give Harry the real
sword however he also explains to Snape
that Harry mustn't know that it was him
who presented him with the sword this is
because Voldemort could potentially use
legitimacy on Harry and figure out
Snape's true Allegiance so instead of
just giving Harry the sword he puts it
in a frozen layer in the forest of Dane
he then uses his corporeal Patronus to
guide Harry to the sword good very good
cred the portrait of Dumbledore Behind
the headmaster's Chair now Severus the
sword do not forget that it must be
taken under conditions of need and Valor
and he must not know that you give it if
Voldemort should read Harry's mind and
see you acting for him at this point
Harry a worthy Gryffindor is reunited
with the relic of his Hogwarts house and
things start to get a little bit easier
but my question is this how on Earth did
Snape find Harry and Hermione in The
Forest of Dean The Forest of Dean is a
geographical historical and cultural
region in the western part of the county
of gloucestershire England that
stretches over 110 square kilometers or
68 square miles it's a thick Woodland
full of trees how did Snape find one
little tent finding a tent alone would
have been a difficult enough task but
toss in the fact that Hermione had
placed all sorts of protective
enchantments over their tents and it
renders finding them nearly impossible
how did Snape do it did Hermione
temporarily forget to cast protective
enchantments did Snape perform
legitimacy or is there another
explanation let me explain after
disapparating Harry engaged Hermione in
conversation by asking where they were
while responding to Harry Hermione
happened to be poking around in her
beaded bag for their tent and it just so
happened that Phineas nigellus's
portrait was able to hear this bit of
discourse Phineas nigellus then relayed
this information to Snape in the
headmaster's office this is shown in the
chapter entitled the prince's Tale in
the Deathly Hallows Headmaster they're
camping in The Forest of Dean the
mudblood do not use that word the
Granger girl then mentioned the place as
she opened her bag and I heard her good
very good quote the portrait of
Dumbledore behind the Headmaster as
chair and that's exactly how Snape knew
without the portrait of Phineas nigellus
I'm not sure how he would have found
them I do have a theory though in the
event their location was never reported
to him maybe Snape could have used his
Patronus you see the Patronus charm
isn't just used as a defense against
dementas it also has other applications
like as a Communications device Patronus
is our spirit Guardians powerful forms
of magic so I don't see why Snape's
Patronus wouldn't have been able to
figure out their location by itself in
this scenario Snape would have simply
operated to The Forest of Dean or not
and sent his Patronus off to find Harry
simple did you guys ever wonder how
Snape found them what videos do you want
next leave a comment down below until
next time remember while we may come
from different places and speak in
different tongues our hearts beat as one
foreign